Why would a person have high sodium?
Mine was a couple points high last time, which has never happened before.
Well, there's really two reasons why you'll have high sodium. What is adrenal stress?
So remember I said low sodium could be a adrenal fatigue. So your adrenal glands you can you can be under stress. Your adrenal glands are functioning well,
but your adrenal glands are hyper stress. That can give you high sodium.
If your adrenal glands are completely fatigued, then you'd see that at an adrenal stress test, as just a straight line on the bottom.
Remember the adrenal stress test where you have higher cortisol levels at certain times in the day in the morning, and then it dips down at night.
It has that nice little curve. Well, somebody who's got adrenal fatigue or adrenal burnout, they have no curve. It's a straight line across.
But a person that has just adrenal stress can be that whole they can have a normal curve, but it can be elevated and that can cause high levels of sodium, but really the most common cause for high sodium is dehydration.
So dehydration, not drinking enough water or drinking too much water. So remember dehydration is from you're not drinking enough water or you're you're you're you're like out in the sun.
Drinking coffee out in the sun or drinking alcohol while you're playing golf on a hot summer day, you could easily become dehydrated and that can cause issues. You can have high levels of sodium that can affect your heart, etc.
But a person could be dehydrated because they drink too much water to so remember those are the two possibilities. So dehydration, most common, adrenal stress is up there too.